that is Scarlett Johansson in Justin
Timberlake's what Goes Around video 2007
remember like I remember well you know
it's fair to say that she is moved on
from those sexy love interest roles very
true but still sucks
yes and the guys better watch out let me
tell you she's playing her third butt
kicking character and I traveled halfway
around the world as guys do for Starlin
to be first on the set of ghost in the
shell'
[Music]
those gunshots to me sounded like 10
times louder than anything I've ever
heard on set you guys are hardcore out
there jumping in doing a deep dive
you're taking cover head stick bullets
which is why they're so loud okay so
right now they're blocking out a scene
that's gonna take four days to shoot one
scene four days yeah
starlet plays a combat-ready cyborg with
a human mind gun-toting and black hair I
like the wig it's my hair it's your real
hair maybe it's not I like your hair out
of my head I like your hair that's what
I meant to say this is a good look as
ROS seen you in this look it doesn't
like it she doesn't like now I think it
would be weird if the person that's your
everything suddenly looks like just not
the person that's your everything
anymore
of course Rose is Scarlett and French
hubby Rome and Orey axe two-year-old
daughter Lucy Black Widow
now major I mean these are some pretty
kick-ass characters yeah I think more
than anything I want my daughter to you
know to feel comfortable taking risks
and know that you know you can that's
sometimes you fail and then when you win
it's it's awesome stick in there man you
gotta fight true it's true though
perseverance is like an wherever
whatever you do peaks and valleys this
is just too beginning and in this world
of Scarlett's task force fighting cyber
criminals
it's got
be high-tech we got like a parade of
awesome cars I saw the interior I
thought maybe it was yours like it's a
baby blue maybe like your eyes Oh looks
like we're in some futuristic Asian
metropolis right no actually we're in
the heart of Wellington New Zealand is
it like less of a paparazzi issue yeah
it's pretty you know I'm pretty low-key
anyway basically just fine toilet paper
and you know getting a so yeah but to
them that's fascinating I mean like if
you're like you know getting Scarlett
Johansson buying toilet paper I mean
though it's all I need it yeah everybody
needs toilet paper the high octane
waiting for yeah I know it's shocking
you long thank you
you rock